aquí dice una sola estampa postal cuesta
44 centavos cuánto costaría un rollo de
mil estampas hay varias maneras de
atacar este problema vamos a hacer el
que yo considero más rápido y también
vamos a hacer uno que es la tradicional
forma de multiplicar decimales entonces
ok vamos a iniciar con esto tenemos 44
centavos entonces 0.44 eso es el costo
de una estampa cuánto costarían diez
estampas bueno entonces una estampa
cuesta 44 centavos así que diez estampas
podemos mover el punto decimal un
espacio a la derecha y después este cero
ya no importa así que sería por diez
estampas 4.4 pesos o lo que es lo mismo
cuatro pesos con 40 centavos ahora qué
pasa si tú quieres comprar 100 estampas
para el caso de 100 estampas es el mismo
es la misma idea movemos otra vez el
punto decimal a la derecha porque
estamos otra vez multiplicando por 10
entonces para 100 estampas estás pagando
y tiene sentido para una estampa pagaste
44 centavos casi 50 centavos entonces
para 100 estampas para las 44 pesos casi
50 pesos entonces como puedes ver
simplemente estamos moviendo el punto
decimal a la derecha porque estamos
multiplicando así que para mil estampas
dado que estamos multiplicando movemos
el punto decimal otra vez a la derecha y
tendríamos 440 pesos para mil estampas
ahora también voy a poner aquí el punto
00 para dejar en claro que que no hay no
hay centavos en este caso así que si lo
quieres hacer rápido iniciaste con 44
centavos y no y dice eso que yo no yo no
multiplique por diez ni por cien
multiplique por mil
entonces movería es el punto decimal a
la derecha tres espacios iría el punto
decimal de estar aquí hasta llegar hasta
acá baja lo que hiciste fue multiplicar
por 10 por 10 x 10 eso es 1000 así que
para mil estampas el costo fue de 440
pesos vamos a verificar si obtenemos lo
mismo si multiplicamos decimales
la tradicional entonces vamos a poner
aquí vamos a multiplicar mil x 0.44 0.44
iniciamos con este 44 por 0 es igual a 0
4 por 0 es igual a 0 y 4 por 0 es igual
a 0 4 por 1 es igual a 4 o lo que es lo
mismo cuatro por mil ajá ahora vamos al
siguiente al siguiente espacio pongo un
cero aquí y entonces 4 por 0 es igual a
0 4 por 0 es igual a 0 4 por 0 es igual
a 0 y 4 por 1 es igual a 4 o lo que es
lo mismo 4 por mil es igual a 4 mil no
vamos a incluir este 0 que puse porque
nos movimos a la izquierda un espacio y
después ya no tenemos nada así que ok
aquí yo no estoy incluyendo los
decimales no estoy tomando los
encuentran os estoy ignorando estoy
simplemente haciendo la multiplicación
pero ahora vamos a sumar esto entonces 0
0200 más 000 0 000 4 0 y 4 más nada es 4
entonces ignoramos el punto decimal
tiene sentido cierto porque estamos
multiplicando 1000 por 4 es igual a 4000
mil por 40 es igual a 40.000 sumamos y
obtenemos 44 mil pero aquí no estamos
multiplicando por 44 sino por punto 44
entonces qué pasa vamos a mover el punto
decimal dos espacios a la izquierda de
la respuesta aquí está el punto decimal
y obtenemos lo mismo 440 pesos para mil
estampas